please be upstanding for the chairman of
the council
thank you thank you members can I ask
you to remain standing for a moment
please I would like to introduce Dr
Reverend Roy Lodge MBE uh
and invite him to lead us in thought and
prayer before today's meeting
good afternoon
councilors and officers and any members
of the public
in an interview with the Sunday Times on
the 25th of June
Terry Waite said this
when I was in the dark cell for most of
the time a little beam of light would
sometimes come through the shutters and
illuminate the room
I would say to myself light is stronger
than Darkness
I must always keep hoping
he went on to say
we believe we should take every
opportunity we can to work for
reconciliation
I'm 84 now
my days are numbered but I can still
make a small positive impact
well whilst not thinking that my life
experience is anything like that of
Terry Waits I do share the same age
and knowledge that my days are numbered
and that in a small way I can still make
a small positive impact even though it's
only writing to The Herald
although celebrating my 85th year this
week
and awaiting hospital admission I hope
to be in attendance as often as I
possibly can
so thank you madam chair for giving me
this opportunity to support you and by
extension all counselors and officers in
your year in office
so may I invite you to share in these
very brief prayerful thoughts at the
commencement of your meeting today
we believe that it is the will of God
that all things should be ordered
peaceably and with Justice
we give thanks for the District of
stratford-upon-avon
for the privilege of holding office
within it
guide with your Holy Spirit or
counselors and officers that they may
work with integrity and transparency
grant them Vision in planning for the
future
responsibility in matters of Finance and
wisdom in the face of difficult
decisions
and sensitivity in dealing with the
marginalized and those in greatest lead
that they may seek in all their purposes
to be faithful to the mind of Christ and
to enrich our common life
through Jesus Christ Our Lord amen amen
thank you thank you
thank you councils
thank you very much for that
I declare this meeting for Council now
open
you may be seated
welcome to this full council meeting
item one on the agenda
first item on the agenda is apologies
for absence David are there any
apologies for absence please thank you
chairman yes there are others apologies
from councilor Jenny frenchly Sarah
Wally hoggins councilor Lewis Adam Ian
franchley Susan nostrander Jillian
padgium down Pemberton Alan scorer and
Dominic Skinner thank you
thank you David
item two on the agenda Declarations of
interest
do any members or officers have any
Declarations of interest for items on
the agenda
just on the outside bodies I am the
chair of Ulster Heritage Trust
uh councilor pedigella
yes and I am the Paris champion of
Parish Council champion and I seeked on
the south water chair safe safers at
Warsaw Community Partnership thank you
thank you uh councilor Coles
thank you I'm the uh stratford-upon-avon
Town Council uh trustee on Stratford
Town Trust
uh Council of elf
thank you I
sit on adult Health overview and
scootenate uh County I'm a town council
member of
stratford-upon-avon Market Forum which
happens to be mentioned three times on
the list for some reason
and then I also so I have an interest in
southwarkshire NHS Foundation trust and
white share health and wellbeing
and
workshare health adult
thank you Council of cancer Curtis
thank you yes I sit on the sparse
thank you
I'm a board member of Shakespeare and
also sit on the Stratford bid thank you
uh councilor grocott
I stand I sit on patrol
um the markets forum and also the
Warwickshire waste partnership
thank you you can add this remind
members to stand please
uh a councilor just
I I sit on the Warwickshire police and
crime panel
um the safer South Warwickshire
Community safety partnership board
and the
um
I can't see it now right
thank you quite a few yeah it's all
right counter guess it's okay I think
there's going to be a general
declaration just just bear with us
moment uh Mr Grafton yeah it seems all
these declarations are around the um the
outside bodies item in which case
there's really no need for any of you to
worry they're not personal interests but
happy for the minutes to note your your
declarations thank you
thank you everybody
um so on to
me sorry I have a declaration
um item six uh appointment of monitoring
officer
it's pretty obvious I have a personal
interest I'll leave the meeting while
you're discussing that thank you
thank you
right moving on to item three the
minutes
um can I seek a proposal and a second
there for the minutes of the meeting
held on the 24th of April
2023. councilor junid I'm happy to to
propose them thank you councilor Junaid
and a second uh councilor Curtis thank
you thank you
happy second
and all in agreement please
a great thank you very much
item four announcements
so we now move on to the announcements
one of my first month as chairman apart
from finding my feet
I've attended two engagements so far
firstly I was honored to attend the
heart of England forest in beautiful
dorsington with fellow counselor Manuel
curtigella and town councilor Danny
Hunter who volunteered to drive me as I
was quite concerned about getting lost
um it was wonderful to see the Queen's
award as it was gifted before the death
of her majesty presented by the Lord
lieutenant
I then attended stratford-upon-avon
Armed Forces Day ceremony having family
members in the air forces
this year was special to me and I'm
thankful to the mayor councilor Kate
Roth for the excellent ceremony
and next up is a picture of the Sea
Cadets who will be my chair one of my
Charities this year they're the only
Cadet group who don't receive central
government funding
yet they do some wonderful work which
I'd like to support
and last but not least
photographed in retirement
Phil science at the Stratford not even
District Council on the 30th of
September 2013 as head of Law and
governance His official last day was the
26th of May but he is covering until
Marcia ecclesson starts officially in
August I'm sure you'll all join me to
wish Phil all the best for the future
thank you
[Applause]
um
and now additionally I would like to
congratulate Matt Stanley who has
recently achieved a long service award
Matt has 25 years service with the
council
um I don't believe he's here today no
but we wish him all the best and thank
him for the hard work he's put in over
that time thank you
[Applause]
and I invite the leader councilman Susan
Junaid to make any announcements
just a few things that I've been doing
uh since I became leader I attended the
West Midlands combined Authority AGM and
also went to their induction day uh to
find out more about what was involved
um during that time I took the chance to
be able to speak to senior officers
about stratford-upon-avon and issues
within Stratford and Penn Haven I
attended a meeting with the chief
executive to meet Mr Burley and who is
the chief executive of the NHS
Foundation Group which was uh to hear
his particular view of things to do with
the shipston hospital I attended the
napton Eco Fair
also the W Warwickshire County Council
climate partnership I attended the local
government Association conference which
again was of a great interest because I
was able to speak to a great many people
that were you know find out what they
were doing and organizations like the
local government Association and the
district council Network and the Town
and Country Planning Association and if
somebody's like that I've attended some
small business events one was organized
by the growth Hub I had a presentation
from hs2 and I gave a presentation to
The Climate action for every one event
which was organized by ulstertown
Council Warwick District Council and
Stratford District Council and this week
I am attending the parish council's
quarterly meeting and that will be on
Wednesday thank you
thank you cancer Gene Ed and I invite
chief executive Dave Brooklyn to make
any announcements thank you chairman
um firstly I just want to refer to an
email that I sent to all members on the
6th of July the email contained a copy
every report which will be presented to
the county council's cabinet on Thursday
this week regarding the the possibility
of exploring discussions surrounding
them joining the West Midland Authority
that the time scales for them to
consider their position are extremely
tight and there would be an implication
that if the County council did become a
constituent member the combined
Authority Under the leveling up and
regeneration Bill we would by default
also become members of the West Midlands
combined Authority as for constituent
members
um through debate with with members
offline we will be establishing a member
working group
cross-party to examine the proposals and
there is a possibility when that working
group has concluded its work that we'll
have to have an extraordinary meeting
the council to confirm the council's
position on this issue there will be a
period of consultation that the County
Council will be running we will need to
form uh into that with our formally
agreed position so just a little bit of
advanced notice that we'll have to meet
over the next few weeks because that is
as I say the the governor through review
is expected to be completed by the end
of July it's looking like they're going
to be making decisions end of September
early October time
I just wanted to talk about some of the
paperwork that you've got on your desks
in front of you as well for this
afternoon in your consideration firstly
I just wanted to touch on the notice of
motion in relation to capitalize each
capitalizing on Military Talent it won't
be debated at today's meeting but I had
been approached to say well aren't we
already signed up to the Armed Forces
Covenant
whilst we did sign up to a version in
2012 we're not current signatories the
most updated version of the Armed Forces
government so that is still an issue
that would need to be discussed
the inpatients review for Ellen Badger
again isn't going to be debated today I
apologize the wrong version of the
notice of motion was reproduced in the
printed version of your agenda you do
have the correct version on on your desk
this afternoon and then finally in
relation to public houses officers had
dialogue with the councilor Parry
subsequent to the agenda being published
the view from officers was that the the
um the recommendation I was drafted was
very prescriptive about how any review
should be undertaken and whilst we could
very well follow that process the
recommendation has been shortened to
give us a bit more scope and latitude in
undertaking a review and that again
won't be debated today but it will be
moved later on
thank you and chairman can I just take
the opportunity for welcome and net
Homer to the room at well and you head
of housing the customer services we've
started with the council last last
Monday
thank you Jim
thank you yes Annette warm welcome to
you from Council
um all right item five public
participation no questions have been
received from members of the public
item six appointment of the monitoring
officer I will just give Mr Grafton a
few moments to to leave the chamber
thank you very much
um I invite the leader to introduce this
report please
with the imminent departure of Phil
Grafton head of Law and governance
monitoring officer is necessary to
review the arrangements in respect to
the statutory role of the monitoring
officer you'll have in front of you item
six uh giving the background and there
is a recommendation there that
um because it requires Council approval
for the appointment of the monitoring
officer that martial Eccleston be
appointed as monitoring officer from the
7th of August 2023 and I've been I'm
looking for a proposal for that
and I'm happy to propose that
yeah thank you
um and now we need a second
uh councilor guest thank you
yes I'm happy to second that
thank you very much are we all agreed
thank you very much
would somebody please like to invite
him back in
thank you
okay Council moving swiftly on item
seven on the agenda south of
neighborhood development plan
um can I invite counselor coucher to
introduce the report please
thank you very much indeed share this
important document went to referendum on
the 22nd of June 2023 and the local
community uh very much endorsed it so
there was a turnout of only 12.2 percent
but there were 707 votes in favor and
only 77 against
um I think it's very important that this
important document is approved by this
Council and I would propose its adoption
thank you very much can I have a second
there please councilor Crump
thank you chairman yeah I'm happy to
second
the recommendations to save them
neighborhood development plan
um what the turnout was was
disappointing
um and I think that's something that the
council might need to look at to
encourage
um
people to participate in such an
important subject
in the future
um it's it's displeasing it was
supported in in such a way loads of
voted uh reporting roughly 90 in favor
and it's got that safe and we'll have a
say in terms of uh what it wants in
developments in the area obviously south
of us had quite a few houses and we need
to make sure we've got the right
infrastructure uh in place for any
additional houses and and it links into
the proposed surf that works your local
plan so slightly long-winded Rumble
there but I do apologize and happy to
Second thank you thank you uh councilor
Crump
um would anybody else like to speak on
this matter
uh yes councilor Bromwich
yeah it's first of all as the person who
helped to get this underway way back
some eight or nine years ago
it's been a bit of a learning curve for
the Paris Council probably a lesson that
other councils should take in note of
the reason this local plan took so long
neighbor plan took so long was quite
simply till we got the course strategy
in place the then political group that
were running the Paris Southern Town
Council didn't show any interest in this
and so when Once the Town Council got
this underway and those subsequent years
I'd like to commend ground faster
Council ground Foster for driving this
along especially we finally got here
but lessons do have to be learned
probably that District needs to probably
be a bit more pushy sometimes towards
the parishes to get these very important
plans in place I think that's one lesson
we would take out from seldom and the
other lesson we'd probably take out of
it is as Council Crump said we probably
need to engage the public a bit more
when it comes to these referendums when
the big complaints I certainly received
on the lead up to this referendum was a
lot of people actually well I've unaware
or didn't have simplified information
they found stuff online but they found
it a bit too long-winded complicated
again that should be a lesson at all
parish councils and this is the district
council should take out of this sort of
any local plan but I'd certainly like to
say thank you very much to all those
involved over the years I've finally got
to this stage and hopefully everybody
here today is going to agree we're going
to adopt that neighborhood plan thank
you very much councilman you're gonna be
outside to speak
okay then thank you counselors um are we
all in agreement
thank you very much
okay
um item eight tredington neighborhood
development plan can I invite cancer
couch again to introduce this report
thank you um and I would certainly Echo
what uh Council Bromwich has said about
how important these plans are if you
haven't got any neighborhood plan in in
position for your community you are at
risk
um in terms of uncontrolled development
and so I would really recommend that for
those parishes that haven't got one need
to get on with it now I'm very pleased
that tredington now joins the the family
of of parishes that already have got one
um and the neighborhood development plan
for tradings and went to referendum
again on the 22nd of June
um please see we had a slightly higher
turnout there at 20.2 percent and there
were 246 votes in favor and only 31
against
um I think as this has clearly been
endorsed by those that showed interest
in in the parish I would recommend that
we adopt at this neighborhood
and support those uh people who put it
together thank you
thank you councilor character
um
can I have a second there for that
please councilor Harvey
thank you chairman I am the member for
tradington
um
this piece of work is the outcome of uh
slog and effort over the last five
Strokes six years
um it it isn't taken uh as read that
these things are going to happen it
depends upon the efforts of those
locally and I have to say whilst there
was a committee uh involved in the work
and they did play their part
the The Lion's Share of the effort and
expenditure of time and sweat was on the
part played on part of counselor John
gimlet and I would be grateful if um our
thanks my thanks in particular to
ex-counselor John gimlet were recorded
in the minutes I say x because the poor
man has decided that in may he is
suffering from exhaustion as a result of
his efforts and I commend him for his
efforts
um if I can pursue briefly the question
of turnout
um
my residence John giblett in particular
was disappointed at 20 turnout I
reminded him that um some of them on the
same day only managed 12 without trying
to score points however I made it my
um practice to go back through past
minutes of meetings and there clearly is
a trend here two years ago for instance
if I take councilor junid's patch of
Ulster the turnout rate was over 39 if I
take councilor rocks uh patch in napton
it was over 57 and the record is held by
Wilmington of 60 turnout those are all
two years ago July 2021 so
this record of the last
um four uh
ndps of this year which have been
approved where 20 is the highest turnout
is is somewhat disappointing and
particularly in relation to the efforts
that have been put in so I think there
are lessons to be learned there's a
trend here and we need to reverse it but
I I do
repeat my request that the my thanks
personal thanks and I hope everybody
else's thanks to councilor John gimlet
is recorded in the minutes thank you
very much
thank you councilor Harvey uh would
anybody else wish to speak
um are we all in agreement
thank you very much
now I did ask members that it's I know
it's been a very long while since a
female sat in this chair but titled
chairperson please rather than chairman
thank you
um item number nine the wells born
campus supplementary planning document
for adoption
a copy of which you will find on your
tables I now invite counselor coucher to
introduce this report
thank you very much indeed
um
this is a very very important site for
this district and is a indication of how
we're taking forward the economy here of
making sure that we have a high-tech
high quality employment sites like this
and the wells one campus and which is a
promoted by the University of Warwick
um on for those of us who've been in
Wellsville for many years known as the
um the HRI site
um it is a very very good Development
coming forward and we've now produced
some supplementary and planning guidance
which obviously will guide new
applications on that particular site
the guidance has been the subject of
extensive local consultation and I'm
very pleased to see that actually the
proposals have been modified certainly
to protect childcare Village and to also
ensure that the Strategic gap between
wellsborn Village and and the uh and the
site is actually maintained as well
I know we are all concerned about
infrastructure provision and clearly
obviously this will put a further burden
on the a429 those will be matters that
will be considered at the planning
application stage but we have noted that
and we've also highlighted the
importance that on sites like this and
that we are looking at making them as
zero carbon as we possibly can and so
therefore we'll be looking for
um looking for in development proposals
come forward
proposals to ensure that that we are
either generating electricity on the
site or that we're actually ensure that
the buildings are are as as
environmentally compatible as at all
possible
um
I would highly recommend this proposal
to you and for I formally propose that
it be adopted
thank you cancer character uh can I call
for a second there please cancel a Parry
thank you thank you chairperson I also
just wanted to make some comments if I
may you may
um
as as the member of the new wellsborn
North and Rural Ward the University of
Warwick campus near Wellsville is now on
my patch
um and as the former portfolio holder
for economic development I together with
the previous conservative Administration
have been extensively involved with this
initiative over the last few years and
in developing relations specifically on
behalf of Stratford district council
with the University of Warwick
as a district we have a major shortfall
of the employment land and economic
development is crucial in terms of
generating High Caliber jobs
the University of Warwick campus SBD is
centered around the concept of creating
Innovation hubs within different zones
and these hubs will be used to promote
interaction Synergy and collaboration
between different organizations and
their specialisms operating throughout
the site
it is also focused on creating local
jobs for local people and the creation
of an innovation Center which aligns
stratford-on-avon with a world-class
University
as the creator of the driving Innovation
and growth Summit last year which
resulted in a hugely successful event in
February this year and a follow-up
session in May in conjunction with the
scale-up Institute I'm in full support
of this supplementary planning document
for those of you who have studied the
proposals in detail you will note there
are additional Community benefits with
plans for relocated Playing Fields
children's nursery Cafe and other
community facilities
whilst I do have concerns about the
Villages of Hampton Lucy and childcott
being used as vehicle rat runs to access
the new campus I am pleased that the
main entry is from the a429 which leads
into the barford bypass and to Junction
15 of the M40 but I'm happy to Second
this proposal thank you chairperson
thank you councilor Perry would any of
the members like to speak
a council of Arc
thank you chairman uh Declaration of
Interest which I um I now make because
of the turn of the debate in that my
daughter is a professor at Warwick
University
thank you councilor councilor Johnson
thank you
chairperson I would like to endorse what
councilor coucher has said and councilor
Parry my principal concern is the
cumulative impact of this application
with other applications that are being
considered for the development of
Wellborn Airfield and the barford
quarries okay one moment please
counselor
member to give consideration to the
cumulative impact on highway safety of
all these developments
take into account a thousand houses in
wellsborn in recent years
this is a single carriageway road that
certainly wasn't designed for this
pressure when it was built and I'm
particularly concerned about the safety
of Walkers and cyclists
okay uh Mr Grafton I just want to um
make clear that we we can't get into the
Realms of or on the edges of in a
potential individual planning
applications in as part of this debate
so on that note does anybody else wish
to speak
thank you
um all those in favor please
agreed
thank you very much
right item 10. counts for questions uh
no counselor questions have been
received
um item 11 questions the leader
please note that up to 30 minutes will
be allowed for questions with each
counselor permitted to speak for no more
than three minutes and may ask no more
than two questions
does anyone have a question to the
leader please
cancer Stanley
thank you chairperson
as the youngest counselor of our group I
believe the youngest female counselor in
this chamber and as a mother of a
two-year-old I am representing those of
my generation those of us who are still
paying our inflated mortgages who are
paying increased fees of child care who
are paying back their student loans who
are working in Stratford on minimum wage
those new mothers and fathers who feel
isolated in their homes with their
newborns who would love to be out of the
house for a few hours to walk around
Stratford Town Center
I want to know what parking concession
do as a leader will be considering for
us and our young families and our
workers
we haven't benefited from a 10 pay
increase like yourself and overstate
pensioners this year we also don't
benefit from free bus passes either and
therefore the decision by cabinet to
reintroduce concessionary concessionary
parking permits just for the Baby
Boomers seven days a week and not even
restricted to Mondays to Fridays is
completely unfair and totally
discriminatory on the grounds of
equality which is exactly why the
permits were previously withdrawn by the
conservative Administration thank you
um yes
I it was actually on November 2019 11th
of November 29th and it was this cabinet
it was the previous cabinet of this
Council that resolved to introduce an
increase in car park tariffs across all
of stratford-upon-avon car Parks
irrespective of income irrespective of
mortgage irrespective of any other
decisions point of order
a point of order please counselor Perry
what is the point of order please
um the leader is not making reference to
the concessionary parking permits
she is coming to the answer if you would
like to wait till the end of the answer
the next item was that on the 11th of
January 2021 uh the cabinet then went on
to to do a number of other proposals and
one of those was to abolish the
concession over 65's permit but at the
same time to increase the hourly tariffs
at all other car parks in the town that
was also considered and moved on through
2021 at various meetings and consulted
upon public consultation took place in
February took March 2021 upon on the
proposals to the parking charges and the
in the February 2023 the cabinet then
endorsed the proposed levels of fees and
charges for 2023-24 which increased
increased and included increases in all
the existing car park terrorists from
the 1st of August 2023 as well as taking
away the over 65's permits they
increased the parking charges for every
other sector of the community quite
substantially across the whole of
Stratford with no other other
concessions
that some of the other concessions that
they took was to abolish the charges to
increase and introduce concessionary
parking charges for the fisherman's car
park but to be do so only by a Ringo app
no um which was discriminatory because
there was no way in which a card payment
could be made one of the things that we
are looking at is not only the
concessionary parking permits for of for
people that are on a pension but also
looking at making sure that everybody
can get their various permits that
whether if they're a resident but want
going forward what is really needed is
also to be able to make sure that young
people and all people of all ages can
easily access the town through the
transport and public transport in
particular I do notice that Warwickshire
County Council that of course is ruled
by the conservatives and many here are
twin Hatters now have had two million
pounds for bus transport and I do hope
that there consider public transport
interstructed upon even as one of the
key things that they can bring to this
town I do hope I'll get um support for
that because that is one way in which we
can make sure that young people and all
people can access the Town Center uh
easily and and improve access to all
facilities within the town thank you
thank you leader
um a councilor put together please
thank you chair
West Midlands trains are proposing to
remove the tickets office from Stratford
upon Avon station
tickets offices are a Lifeline for
vulnerable passengers the elderly and
disabled and for the thousands of
visitors to our historic town does the
leader agree that this closure will not
modernize the railway because confusion
and safety issues and sadly contribute
to further digital exclusion for many of
our residents
a greatly sympathize with exactly what
you're saying
um I went to uh Warwick I went to
Stratford Parkway actually not very long
ago and found that most of the
um the payment machines were either not
working or would only accept coins and
not cards uh and I then went to had to
go to Stratford uh uh station uh in
order to be able to get a train to
Birmingham I have to say that the ticket
office there were extremely helpful in
supporting my inquiry I also had to go
down to the local government Association
conference recently and because of
industrial action there were three
different changes on the train down to
Bournemouth and I have found that the
the ticket office at Warwick Parkway
were extremely supportive to me I got
there and found that there was no mobile
phone signal therefore I could not use
the Ringo app because there was no
mobile phone signal they I had to go
into the ticket office and the ticket
office were very very supportive and
helpful in an international town like
this with people coming in from all over
the world visiting Stratford I I
actually think we need do need to be
able to put our case forward and there
is a consultation and I do propose that
we put the consultation response in to
the government response about staff in
ticket officers thank you thank you uh
councilor bomwich
0.2
no it's your question please
yeah so this is going to be a slightly
little bit of a long-winded thing in a
roundabout way because many of the old
councils will go in here that I actually
foster two of my family members that
both 15 years old both come from very
difficult backgrounds that
one of the things that they often say to
me and it's never been brought up really
in my time on this council is what does
Stratford District Council do for kids
around our age and it got me thinking
well actually we've had many discussions
about younger generation than these
teens the senior citizens lots of people
in between and that but actually we have
never really sold anything to that sort
of age group
for me to stand there and get people
interested in things like councils we
have to really say what we are doing for
them so my question to the leader is
over the next four years
what are we going to do for our
teenagers which hopefully then will help
reduce things like anti-social Behavior
which in places like South most
certainly on the up I suggest because
kids are very bored at the moment now
amongst many other reasons
and is it not time we started thinking
about people not just because they're
voters but also because they could be
future voters
um support for young people is something
that is very dear to my heart I've
actually run Ulster youth project in
Ulster for about 10 years raised
something like 60 000 pounds for making
sure that uh work is done
um for young people including matching
uh money that came from this District
Council for for a player area it is
something that we do need to do more of
we need to work in partnership with the
Warwickshire County Council who are
responsible or used to be responsible
for Youth Services I think there is very
little Youth Services anywhere now and I
do need to make we do need to make sure
uh that we are working with those that
can provide and can find the money to
make sure that we are working with young
people one of the things that it was in
my Manifesto is that we will make sure
for example uh that we will encourage
and support not only jobs for young
people but making sure that affordable
genuinely affordable homes are available
for the next Generation within our
District it's something that I feel very
strongly about not only because I I have
children as well and grandchildren but
we know we do need to make sure that we
are not a a district that is of a
particular age group we have to make
sure that we've got we're preparing for
the future and that housing is one of
the things I feel very very passionate
about but it's also as you say
um making sure that activities are
around and I have already had a meeting
with officers about antisocial behavior
and it's again something we will be
picking up thank you
thank you leader uh councilor power your
second question please
thank you uh chairperson leader as a
district councilor representing
wellsborn over the last nine years and
having been extensively involved in the
protection of wells-bourne Airfield
please can the leader give my residence
cast on reassurance that the money set
aside in SD's budget will continue to be
ring fence to protect the legal option
of serving a compulsory purchase order
on the Airfield owners if deemed
necessary in order to mean the pressure
on the future of the site for enhanced
flying functions and employment Land
Development with no housing thank you
I I am I have not made any instructions
to be able to for that money to be used
in any other way at the moment and then
we'll get seek guidance from the chief
executive uh as to that uh that fund but
I have not directed it for it to be used
for any other purpose other than
protecting the the Wellsville Airfield
we must make sure for example that what
the outcome for that field is uh and
I've got my my portfolio over here has
already spoken about uh this to me and
making sure that we get a suitable
development there
uh thank you uh councilor Crump please
councilor Harvey was before me sorry no
I don't believe he was there's actually
another person in front of him all right
then
I'm happy to come in Madame chairperson
um
just for us into balance I went to the
LJ recently from from lemington Spar and
ticket machines were working fine even I
could use them so that was all good
um I'm often tired of many faults um but
my memory is currently okay I think if I
can remember that a few years ago a
member of The Rolling group spoke
strongly against the introduction of the
green bin subscription this member
stated that the resident had a choice of
putting food on the table or buying a
subscription
will this charge be removed no you are
in power
have you got um guidance as to how um
you are would reverse your budgets the
the into which you uh voted to use that
money uh I don't I think it's it's
normally not the process to you know
overturn something but which is already
written into the budget statement
um if perhaps if you've got suggestions
as to how we could uh cut the budget and
reduce Services as you may have done
over the last few years then maybe we
can move forward
thank you leader
no
I'm sorry
I'll come back to him shortly then oh no
okay councilor Crump you have a second
question
yes I wasn't going to but it's just a
follow-up to that it seems that you can
change things when you want to
particularly around the parking permit
but can't change it around the uh the
actual green bin so a bit of contradict
to that and I thought it part of being
the working party working at
Administration it's up for you to come
up with ideas not for us as in
opposition thank you
there's no question there uh so what was
the actual
question sorry I can I missed it
Immortal instead of talking to Mr
Grafton I thought you might have heard
that
um but um but we won't go any further
um I'll put my clothes away now the
question was
how come
you can't make a decision to reverse the
green waste subscription but you can
make a decision to reverse the parking
permit that's got
um was part of the budget proposals of
the previous administration doesn't that
seem to sound contradictory
I think we're talking a very different
um the green bin for example is 1.8
million uh that we would have to find
the parking permit if you remember you
were represent an area that has no car
parking charges for for your town and
most of you actually have no car parking
charges for your town there are a case
was made to us here that there are
people in the town who have um find it
very difficult not only to come in to
meet friends but also to volunteer in
some of the charity shops if you
remember that Stratford and uh there is
a small car park in shipston Stratford
is the only area that does have car
parking charges and I think the case was
made that um some of some of the older
people do need to socialize do need to
keep healthy do need to shop and and
particularly they do need to volunteer
in in the in the charity shops and I do
know that I spoke to one charity shop
and they had lost volunteers as a result
of of the charges I think until we get a
decent bus service coming into the town
and think we have to be we have to look
after some of our old people we it is
not fair to ask somebody who's in their
80s to 90s who are struggling and has no
bus service at all to be able to come
into town and and wants to come in on a
once or twice weekly basis I think we
you know we are talking here
um and I haven't had I've had a look at
the car park
um to which it is to be introduced and
it is not full so it is not really a
budgetary issue in the way that green
beans is 1.8 million which we would have
defined if we wanted to reverse that
thank you thank you Rita uh councilor
Bromwich please
leader in doing this parking concession
regardless of whether it's of a free car
parking house across the district in
places like southam it will be seen as a
tax break for people who can afford to
operate cars
therefore the essence of Southern would
rightfully say they could afford to pay
parking charges the residents of
Southern would tear out and argue
it says no benefit to them their nearest
places they would go and the likes of
Leamington Spa whether it be paying car
parking charges boundary rugby Coventry
daventry they'd all be paying parking
charges the same to actually go and
undertake the very things that you
highlighted here
so leader how can you justify a tax
break for the people of Stratford to use
and within the vicinity of Stratford to
the people inside them who will stand
there and I can tell you now I can see
the social media posting coming up
saying once again Stratford District
Council looks after Stratford Town
itself because that has always been a
great and you have now just reinforced
that Vision to a lot of senior citizens
so what can you offer the people of
southam in return to the concession of
the tax break to the residents are
strapped for town
I understand that in southern you have
free car parking
it I think that is correct
you have free car parking Stratford is
the only Town other than a small car
park in shipston that has car parking
charges
uh thank you your question is now has
been answered thank you we have to look
further forward we have to have Vision
to look to to make sure that there is
proper public transport across the
district which is does not exist at the
moment and and perhaps you would like to
tell there's a small group of people
that come into my town which again does
not have car parking charges they come
in uh regularly on to the one of the
cafes
they're all widows they've all lost
their husbands within the last five to
ten years
can I tell you that as somebody who's
lost my husband the chance to be able to
go in and be able to talk and meet with
my friends even if it's only once a week
but on a once a week basis is a Lifeline
I think we have to have a little bit
more compassion for people that are in
their older ages in the in their 70s 80s
90s who do need to be able to keep in
touch with their friends now please if
if you all want to me to introduce car
parking charges to all of your car park
your towns please be the first ones to
line up and I will make sure that I tell
them
thank you
thank you Council uh councilor Harvey
please
thank you chairperson
in the manifesto in which you stood on
May the 4th Council of junid you
promised that and I quote in everything
that we do we will engage with residents
consult and ensure our work remains
rooted in the communities we serve
not only did you promise to consult on
everything you also promised to
fundamentally review the council's
policies and the processes for Resident
consultation
so that my residents know that you're
going to consult them on everything you
do and so that you know they did not
cast their vote on the basis of an empty
promise
could you please outline for them what
the issues or policies are that you plan
to consult residents over
the next 12 months would do
how many consultation exercises your new
administrations Intel intends will take
place over that period
your estimate of the likely cost to the
public purse of conducting a typical
cons consultation exercise and finally
will you commit your Administration to
report to Council on the outcome of your
promised review of the current
consultation policies and if so when
will that report be available
in short counselor junid just how much
of a saccharine empty election promise
was this
enough
can can I just say that consultation is
not always done through a official means
however I have already met
um the officers of this Council about
the consultation process and how that is
done and I can say that we have
excellent counselors here excellent
Council officers here who really do do
it and actually work for other councils
um on consultation processes they really
do understand the processes so I've
already had a meeting with them and
there is a Clark's meeting a parish
clerks meeting they caught one of the
quarterly ones this coming week and I've
already got a parish council champion
who has already contacted the
Warwickshire Association of local
councils and the uh about making sure
that she goes to as many parish councils
as possible I've also started that
approach about talking to counselors
about coming out and I've started by
going out to for example I went out to
napton to the Eco fair to make sure that
I met with people there and I intend to
come out to studly and I've already
spoken to the counselor about from
studly about what about going out to
that there and I will do that across the
areas as many as as many as possible I
would also like to invite counselors uh
as part of any consultation that they
feed back to me what is happening in
their areas and I that is an open
invitation to all councilors from all
groups from all political groups because
I do need to be able to meet make sure
that I am hearing about their concerns
in their areas that is as a wise
consultation because as cancers of
course you will have your uh your
fingers on all the details that go on in
your Council areas and I will do that as
much as possible I have maintained the
annual I think it's every month uh
column in the herald in order to be able
to keep in touch with people uh I there
is many many ways in which we can keep
in touch with our residents and it's my
I um my it was my in my Manifesto that I
will do that and that I do it fully
intend to do that it only does not only
have to be done through formal means
although that will be a useful tool as
well
thank you uh Council of rock please
thank you madam chairperson
um
I refer to a question that was uh
earlier on uh leader did we not discuss
at some considerable length at cabinet
the prospect of approaching Warwick
District Council for a reciprocal scheme
with them to benefit those Wards to the
north of the district and uh did we was
it not discussed at length at the
scrutiny committee as to how we could do
that and we will be we have instructed
officers to make that approach to see
whether we could
carry that out as I indicated in the
previous term when we were in opposition
I can I can agree with that one that
exactly is what we've done we've all
been in touch with Warwick District
we've made that instruction to make sure
that you we can get um piggyback on the
reduced fares that Warwick District
Council has we will report back once we
get an answer
thank you uh councilor shenton please
thank you chairperson
um
climate change obviously is close to
your heart leader as it is to to me and
to everyone else in December 2021 the
current Administration put forward a
motion to substantially increase tree
cover
across the district from seven percent
to around 14 and sorry there's a matter
of some urgency
The Proposal involves significant
investment way above the early council
tax received from residents but I am
assuming
that the leader and the cabinet still
have an appetite to carry this through
so my question is when can we and by we
I mean councilors and residents alike
see the plans for for achieving this
brought forward and how will it be
funded
sure that we all op offers and all
options are open for the tree planting
in September once it you know that you
can't plant trees in in the middle of
summer you have to wait until I say I do
believe I've got a meeting coming up
with one organization that would look at
biodiversity net gain and I as you know
I am a trustee Warwickshire Wildlife
trust I will feed back to you once we've
got details back from them
thank you Rita uh Council evolve please
uh thank you madam chairperson uh just
to answer councilor bromwich's um uh
queries
um
councilor this is questions to the
leader please
so uh leader please will you put a
question to the conservative run County
Council as to how they are going to
improve bus services to Villages outside
Stratford where people live that up
until the conservatives took away the
concessionary partying permit were
coming into Stratford they're now going
to lemington Wells born shipston some
are free parking some are certainly Less
in price parking than Stratford so
please will you put a question to the
conservative run County Council if
they'd like to spend some of their 2
million pounds on improving bus services
to our outline Villages so that we don't
have to have a concessionary parking
permit thank you
yes I am very happy to put that I've
already mentioned that the fact that
that um the County Council has the two
million bus service
um the fund that has come from
government I do believe that some of it
should come to the South one of my
concerns it was mentioned earlier about
the West Midland combined up Authority
one of my concerns is that if the
Warwickshire County Council does move in
that direction and of course we cannot
prejudge that then transport would go go
into a West Midlands combined Authority
Metropolitan uh fund for transport it is
essential that our rural areas do have
proper transport thank you okay thank
you then
um and that's all the questions so thank
you very much uh councilors uh
moving on to item 12. notice of motion
this is this is for information only on
item 12.
okay
um
so just for update thank you um item 13
motions are notice
we have four emotions on notice
the first one being capitalizing on
Military talent in accordance with
Council procedure rules once proposed
unseconded the motion will be referred
to the cabinet for consideration and
Report without debate
this motion we proposed by councilor
parry and then seconded by councilor
Stanley councilor Parry thank you
thank you madam chairperson very pleased
to propose this motion all the details
are contained within the documents
um and we obviously look forward to
hearing response from cabinet and due
course thank you thank you councilor
parry and to be seconded by councilor
Stanley please thank you madam
chairperson yes uh reiterate what
councilor Parry says I'd be happy to
have second this motion
thank you very much
um that will
that that will go to cabinet thank you
motion number two impatience bed review
Ellen Badger Hospital in shipston
in accordance with Council procedure
rules once proposed and seconded the
motion will be referred to the cabinet
for consideration a report without
debate
um the following motion we posted by
councilor pertigella yes thank you madam
chairperson
um I like to propose the impatience bed
review Ellen Badger Hospital
motion thank you thank you very much and
could I please invite counselor passing
him to set second emotion
I would I would like to second the
motion
thank you very much
okay item number three
um
membership of outside bodies
this motion was proposed and seconded
will be debated
the following motion will be proposed by
councilor Parry please and seconded by
councilor Fleming
Council Parry
thank you madam chairman
uh this motion would have been proposed
by councilor Wally hoggins had she been
able to attend today if she's committed
elsewhere
but I'm happy to propose this whilst it
is self-explanatory the key thrust of
this motion focuses and highlights just
some of the many outside bodies that SDC
has close connections with that I'm sure
both our residents and some of the
members are not readily aware or what
their functions are it therefore makes
sense particularly in view of all the
new councilors now with SDC and the
start of a new Council to have greater
Clarity and accountability in respect to
those members who are now representing
the district's interests so that both
our residents and members know who to
contact be aware of when meetings are
taking place in order that they can make
a contribution should they so wish and
also be aware of what goes on at these
meetings by having agendas and minutes
published on a specific outside bodies
area of the SD's website whilst the list
outlined in the council papers today is
not exhaustive carrying out such an
exercise will also determine the merits
of having representation on these
outside bodies together with their
importance and relevance I also think
this exercise should also be referred to
overview and scrutiny Committee in order
that they can be fully adjusted and
considered thank you madam chairperson
thank you councilor Parry uh could I
please invite councilor Fleming to
second the motion please
uh thank you madam chairperson I served
on some of these committees and I fully
endure what kinds of counselor Perry has
asked and I second in motion thank you
okay thank you very much councilor
Fleming for seconding that
um I am aware there is an amendment to
this
uh Council of rock please
uh thank you madam chair person
um I would like to propose an amendment
uh to the motion it's been put forward
uh by the earlier councilors uh can I
say uh the words key thrust was
mentioned in uh in proposing the motion
on I do agree with the key thrust of it
but before you is um a paper with some
revised wording uh that wording is uh to
make it easier to achieve the objectives
that I think we mutually have and I move
the amendment
thank you very much do I have a second
there for that motion for the amendment
please uh Council valve thank you yes
you do and I reserve my right to speak
thank you okay thank you councilor Rolf
um
uh were there any other member like to
speak on this issue please
uh councilor Parry
thank you madam chairperson whilst I
welcome
um the same considerations from
counselor rock on our motion he
obviously agrees it's it it is something
that is well needed
um and I and and I know his amendment
has been put forward
um as a friendly Amendment however I do
feel it's really important that when you
have got 39 bodies that are currently
being
represented by not only Council officers
but also members it's really important
that when it comes down to it if you're
going to delete one of those
associations or members it should all
come back as a final list of
recommendation in front of osc just in
the interest of democracy and I would
hope that councilor Rock would be in
support of that very small adjustment to
his friendly Amendment thank you thanks
thank you councilor councilor Crump
please
thank you madam chairperson
we're all very busy we all know how busy
people are both members and officers and
we need to make sure we use officer time
wisely
we've already seen how
how heavy their workload is we've have
issues of vacancies recruitment and
retention
so we need to make sure we we are using
our offices wisely
so
you know as chair of over in scrutiny I
do think this is an error a topic we
should be looking at to make sure that
we are attending these outside bodies
for the right reasons
the the minutes are published and also
that we're actually using off officer
time wisely because they can't be in two
places at once so whilst our these
meetings or supporting members who are
actually going there instead of the
offices and they can't be getting on
with the day job so slight slight
disagreement okay so I can understand
the thrust of it but I still would like
to see some referral to overview and
scrutiny please
thank you
all right Council of off would you like
to speak now
um oh are we in debate or not
which one are we debating sorry debating
the amendment
so it's councilor locks Amendment we are
now debating please
uh Council up please
just not quite sure where we were there
thank you
um so I uh we've got a very interesting
that we I didn't get the chance to have
a full go at this but um first of all I
said earlier on uh we fully support the
the thrust of this we want to make
things more open more transparent more
effective uh certainly the list of names
I think the uh I underlined everything
in in the original motion that I think
is covered by this
um the the reason this wording has come
about is has come about in consultation
with officers to make uh a pragmatic way
of achieving this now a couple of
speakers have said they'd like to see
this go to scrutiny there are no words
in this that prevents scrutiny looking
at this the first thing is we need to
know what it is we're looking at so I
think we need this review of the outside
bodies we need to know who's on it and
and the mechanisms for dealing with it I
have to say that in the recent trains of
administration one of the first things
that happened is we were called into
various offices and presented with a
list of outside bodies
now clearly I've been a counselor before
I presumably knew it was a very large
list but it was very intimidating when
we had to appoint people to this list
the list is very long
uh and it's not entirely clear as the
motion suggests what the function of
these bodies are how long they've been
there how effective they are and
certainly the reporting back has
been let us say patchy so I think the
first thing we need to do is to carry
out a review get officers to help us
with this find out uh what they they all
are purporting to do
the other thing to point out that this
is another reason for the rewording
we're not in control of these outside
bodies we're not in control of their
constitution or the activities that go
there so we can't make commitments on
their behalf uh in the case of many of
them but what we can do is we can
replicate their agendas and minutes and
so on on our website well by virtue of
only a link because we there's so many
of them at the moment
if someone deleted as a result of this
or perhaps I hesitate to say other ones
I did but um there are a number of ones
that are informal and not on the list I
mean there's been some conversation
recently about an a46 group I sit on an
hs2 group with Jeremy Wright there's
lots of ones that are going on that uh
perhaps should be on this list that are
not there so I think the first thing we
need to do is to go through this list
systematically ask the officers to do
that and then come back as it suggests
to council and those at a cabinet and
leader appointments we deal with those
first then if somebody wants to suggest
that scrutiny could look at that and I'm
looking at the chairman of scrutiny I'm
sure he'd be delighted to do it in due
course they they can have a look at that
and call that call that to their
committee should they wish to do so it
doesn't preclude that happening but the
first thing we have to do is to get it
under a belt as to what's going on so
thank you madam chairperson
thank you councilor work uh councilor
off we speak now
uh yes I do thank you uh madam
chairperson
so um
when you were in charge over the
previous 22 years
did any of your residents ask you about
um your representation on these outside
bodies because we as opposition in those
days did ask you many many times I've
been I'm in my 16th year of being a
counselor we asked you so many times for
reports coming back from outside bodies
and we never got anything so your
residents didn't know either at least we
are suggesting that we are completely
transparent about the list of outside
bodies some of them are duplicated
horrendously so there aren't quite as
many as you've put forward but please
don't throw it back on us when you know
that you made a huge mistake when you're
in charge by not letting your residents
know who was on what group who was on
what outside body and you certainly
never let us know either at the time
thank you thank you councilor
yes this is why I declared an interest
at the beginning about the Ulster
Heritage Trust because there is a
representative from as an outside body
that sits on that I can report to you
that I am the chair and it was a
decision taken by the trustees the whole
body of the trustees that they do not
want a representative of Stratford
District Council on that trust and the
reason is that they have never seen
either of the previous two
Representatives that were put on by The
District Council in eight years and
they've just taken that decision uh that
um now that the building is leased to
the County Council and it's not a
directly owned building by The District
Council
um that um that they can't really see a
purpose they say they've not had a
representative that's appeared for eight
years
thank you councilor Gene Ed councilor
brummage please
yeah just listening to all this at the
moment counselors we're not making
ourselves sounding good when we try
political points scoring what we're
trying to do is solve a problem solve a
problem here
so the Motions before us I think we're
all common sense enough to know that we
should just make a list
we should find out who we're actively
engaged with and if we're not actively
engaged with then that's something we
should take up and find out why and then
find out if that body wants to be it
still I'll represent have
representations with Stratford District
Council so I don't think we need to be
debating the Rights and Wrongs of the
past we need to be looking to do forward
let's apply some common sense now get
the list done what's we need to do
statutory-wise get that done anything
else that we can just put before
overviews of scrutiness make sure
everybody's all happy with it and it
saves us into here for Endless hours of
debate for something that's be quite
simple to do
thank you
um
is there any other cancers we should
speak please
right we are going to vote on the
amendment please
um
all in favor please
that's carried thank you all very much
Carrie for the amendment
like okay
just done right um
next motion public houses please
counselor councilor counselors Becky
pardon in accordance with Council
procedurals once proposed and seconded
the emotion will be referred to the
cabinet for consideration and Report
without debate the following motion be
posed by councilor Parry
I'm on overtime here Madam chair person
um delighted to propose this motion
um and I know I have a very strong
seconder thank you thank you councilor
Perry uh and councilor shenton to second
please thank you madam chair president
um although there's been a decline in
the overall number of Rural public
houses there's been little to no decline
in the importance of the rural Pub they
play an important social cultural and
economic role so it's in this light that
I second the motion
thank you can I just make it clear that
it's revised recommendation on your
table
that task and finish group be
established to fully explore how the
council can provide greater protection
in relation to the preservation of
public houses
okay just make it completely clear
um that will go to cabinet thank you
um 1815 please urgent business
and there isn't any thank you
counselors
um the next meeting of the cancer will
take place on Monday the 16th of October
2023 there being no further business I
declare the council meeting closed
thank you